imagine
being a fossil touring the world's great
museums
inspiring awe and onlookers of all ages
posing for hordes of fawning
photographers
sound like something you'd like well
good luck
at least 99.9 percent of creatures that
have
ever lived aren't preserved in the
fossil record
but forget about them everyone else will
and listen
up if you want your corpse in the
exclusive
0.01 club the hall of preserved fossil
fame
it will not be easy you
better work step one
die it's a cold hard fact of
fossilization
everything paleontologists find was once
alive and at some point
died we'll skip the details and assume
you had a
long fulfilling life so we can get to
what's really important
how you die
there are many ways to become a fossil
so let's highlight your top
death options you could get yourself
trapped in tree sap which when hardens
turns into amber and can survive intact
for millions of years
but unless you find a really big tree to
sit under
amber preservation will likely remain
the domain of insects and other very
small animals
generally the right place to be if you
want to end up a fossil is wherever
sediment is
actively being deposited like a lake or
an ocean floor
a mountaintop or prairie not good
you need to get buried the faster the
better because the longer you hang
around on the surface the more likely
you'll get eaten
scavenged or otherwise destroyed before
ever having a chance to get preserved
if you can get buried someplace with
little to no oxygen like a bog or a deep
lake bottom
even better that lack of oxygen will
slow down your decay and give you more
time to
fossilize so let's say you're lucky
enough to die
and get buried in a shallow sea under
muddy sandy sediments
what's your next move one option is a
process called per mineralization
while all your soft parts decay away
your bones get saturated with
mineral rich waters bit by
bit microscopic crystals precipitate out
of these waters to fill in the empty
spaces and pores in your bones otherwise
you'd better hope the sediments around
you harden while your bones decay away
and another sediment or mineral fills in
the spaces your bones leave behind
creating a perfect cast of your skeleton
over time the sediments around your
fossil will lithify
or turn into rock but you're not in the
clear yet
many things could happen to those
sedimentary rocks that might destroy
your chances of getting discovered
they could get uplifted into a mountain
range and eroded away
or carried along in an oceanic plate and
subducted back into the earth's mantle
melting your fossil into a hot mush
fingers crossed your rock surroundings
will get gently lifted up by plate
tectonics
sea levels will change and you'll end up
under dry land
close to the surface but not so close
that erosion from wind and rain wipes
you away before someone can come find
you
the last step in this long process
an intrepid paleontologist has to come
find you
maybe she's a research scientist
scouting for fossils your age and type
or just an amateur collector hoping for
a fortuitous find
she whacks away at layers of rock above
you
or spots your fossil exposed in a creek
bank after a flood
and there you are a magnificent
scientific discovery millions of years
in the making
she and her colleagues gently extract
you from the surrounding sediment
measure and photograph all the bits and
pieces they find
and begin the complex task of
reconstructing how and when you lived
based on the evidence they find
in your bones paleontologists will be
some of your
biggest fans along with all those
admiring crowds at the museum
you made it you spent
years underground in obscurity shedding
blood
sweat tears and your internal organs
you worked yourself to the bone till
your
bones disintegrated and were replaced by
minerals and sediments
but it was all worth it
because you're a famous fossil
now you better hold that pose
you